then yesterday at the National Book Fair
and now we're back live this next
program is harold kushner rabbi hero of
harold kushner and his book is called
living a life that matters he was
previously known for his book when bad
things happen to good people
we'd also tell you that if you would
like more information about the Miami
Book Fair you can go to their website
Miami Book Fair dot-com and if you have
any comments for book TV about our
coverage this weekend of the Miami Book
Fair you can go to our website at book
TV org and email us through that
good evening ladies and gentlemen this
is it
my name is Barbara Egan I'm the
co-chairman of Miami Book Fair
International and it is my pleasure to
welcome you to the final presentation of
Miami Book Fair this year our 18th year
we are thrilled to have this particular
speaker author wonderful person to help
us face the whole year when we're not
gonna have Book Fair to introduce him I
would like to introduce to you someone
who has had a profound effect on all of
us who live in Miami was the former
editor of publisher excuse me of the
Miami Herald and now he is heavily
involved in early childhood education
something that will affect us for
generations to come
please welcome David Lawrence
thank you
ladies and gentlemen almost all of you
already know our speaker tonight native
of Brooklyn graduate of Columbia author
of several bestsellers including when
bad things happen to good people which
is available in a dozen languages holder
of numerous honorary degrees and other
awards and rabbi laureate of a temple in
Massachusetts his newest book living a
life that matters is a book written by a
man of compassion and wisdom and
forgiveness he knows that all of us lead
somewhat conflicted lives our souls are
split rights the rabbi part of us
reaching for goodness part of us chasing
fame and fortune and sometimes doing
questionable things along the way as we
realize that those two paths may diverge
sharply much of our lives much of our
energy will be devoted to closing that
gap between the longings of our soul and
the scoldings of our conscience between
our two often conflicting needs for the
assurance of knowing that we are good
and the satisfaction of being told that
we are important this book is a splendid
blend of history and Bible philosophy
and prayer and wisdom and goodness the
rabbi writes of the tension that exists
in all of us quote only morally
sensitive people struggle with the gap
between who they are and who they know
they ought to be you cannot be a whole
person the rabbi tells us a complete
person without having to wrestle with
your own demons and for that matter your
own angels ladies and gentlemen the
rabbi can speak for himself
and you came to hear him we have with us
this evening a writer of wisdom a man of
faith and humanity a teacher who raises
all the most important human questions
and a good man who helps us all find
some of the answers rabbi
harold kushner rabbi
good evening David thank you very much
for that introduction after saying all
those nice things about me I could
hardly wait to hear what I have to say
and thank you all for coming out to
share this next hour it doesn't take
very much to persuade me to come down to
Miami
especially to leave Boston for Miami
November but at any time to come down to
the city where our daughter and
son-in-law and our grandchildren live
and they are always very much of a
magnet ever since they settled here some
seven and a half years ago and our
son-in-law opened his orthodontic
practice on Kendall Drive at the corner
of 137 Avenue
and it's especially gratifying to come
down for what is a celebration of books
I was a consumer of books long before I
became a producer of books and for me
not only because of the Jewish tradition
I come out of but simply because of what
I have learned to take seriously in life
I have learned to consider books to be
sacred objects and so this Miami Book
Fair which celebrates the book is a
place for which I've often longed to be
invited and I thank you for making this
part of our row our visit this time
heard a story recently about a writer
who was trying to impress an attractive
young woman he just been introduced to
and he said to her by the way have you
read my last book and she answered I
hope so
so I'll be telling you tonight I hope
not about my last book but about my most
recent one the one that David Lawrence
told you about living a life that
matters and David that you've made it
very easy for me by choosing for your
introduction the most salient passages
from the book you save me several
minutes of telling these people what the
book is about the premise underlying the
book is that every person has two
fundamental needs the need to feel
important is one the need to know that
the world takes you seriously I read a
memoir recently of a woman remembering
her childhood and recalling that when
she was about 8 years old and she had to
stay home from school one day because
she wasn't feeling well and in the
course of the morning as she's staying
home she hears the noises of the world
outside and it bothers her so much that
the world is going on without her she
would have expected the very least the
world would stop and wait for her to
rejoin them and that woman grows up to
be a social activist a pillar of her
community a leader of her church always
writing letters to Congress picketing
marching for various causes and one
suspects that she grew up in that
direction to make sure she would never
again have that feeling that the world
doesn't really make much to care very
much if she's there or not this needs to
feel important it's why doctors work 18
hours a day to find cures for disease to
cure patients it's why creative artists
labor so hard to find just the right
color just the right note just the right
word to add to the amount of beauty in
the world the need to feel important is
why your neighbor buys six copies of the
local paper because it has his name in
it it can be in the police report it
doesn't matter
getting his name on the paper makes him
feel he really exists and I suspect that
that need explains something that has
long puzzled me why people appear on
daytime television shows Jerry Springer
Montel Williams Sally Jessy Raphael and
revealed the most embarrassing secrets
of their dysfunctional families and you
look at them and you say why are these
people going public with their their
embarrassment for an hour they will be
mocked and laughed at but for an hour
they will have held the attention of an
entire nation they will have been taken
seriously and these are people who just
don't get that anywhere else in their
lives the need to be taken seriously I
can believe that Lee Harvey Oswald
killed President Kennedy and John
Hinckley jr. tried to kill President
Reagan in order to prove to the world
that they were wrong in dismissing them
they were not anonymous insignificant
people they had the power to change the
course of history that's one of our
needs so we all have it the second one
is the need to think of ourselves as
good people if any of you have young
children at home I wonder if you've had
this experience you catch your child
having done something wrong and the
evidence is unmistakable pieces of the
broken lab at their feet chocolate
smeared all over their face and they
insist they didn't do it they're not
lying to you and they're not trying to
fool you they are trying desperately to
hold on to their image of themselves as
good people that's why the word
rationalise exists in the English
language
what is rationalized mean it means
persuading yourself but something you
know is wrong is really okay and it's
only to persuade yourself it never fools
anybody else but we need to do it we
need to do it because we cannot let go
of the image of ourselves as good people
a friend of mine a psychologist in
Cambridge Massachusetts who works with
teenage gang members and with prison
inmates told me that when he first got
into that line of work
he was sure he would be dealing with the
lowest forms of
life of human life imaginable people
with no scruples no moral convictions
whatsoever to his astonishment he found
out that prisoners and gang members have
a very strict code of morality it may
not be our morality it may not be one we
want to live by but think about it gang
members will risk life and safety to
protect the fellow gang member
prison inmates know that they will gain
status if they refuse to rat on their
associates no matter what inducements
are dangled in front of them and they
will lose status if they're imprisoned
for harming women and children and they
all live by those rules so there you
have as David Lawrence alluded to the
needs to feel good about yourself and
the needs to feel important if you're
lucky they will never conflict you will
find the cure for cancer win the Nobel
Prize and get your picture on the cover
of Time magazine and everything will be
fine if you're not that lucky you may
find yourself cutting ethical corners to
win the prize you crave this is the
salesman who exaggerated the virtues of
his product to close the sale this is
the lawyer who uses emotional techniques
on a jury to gain the verdict that he's
after this is the political candidate
who is so convinced that the future of
the Republic depends on his being
elected that he gives himself permission
to mislead the public about his opponent
to plant rumors to distort his opponents
record if he doesn't like doing it
because he's fundamentally a decent
person he feels guilty doing it but he
can't keep from doing it because he
feels it's so important for him to win
that election and that's why the hero of
my new book is the biblical patriarch
Jacob because that's the story of his
life the divided soul Jacob of those who
were in synagogue yesterday you read the
story clearly Jacob is a man who does
things that he knows are wrong things he
doesn't like doing but feels he has to
do them to gain the prize that he feels
entitled to
he cheats his brother he deceives his
father he tries to fool his
father-in-law Laban who's bigger crook
than he is and all the time
dislikes himself hates himself because
he's doing it and it all comes to a head
the night that he wrestles with the
angel if I can remind you of the story
from your Sunday school days here's the
context Jacob has been out of the
country for 20 years he got in the jam
at home he did some embarrassing things
fled to live with his uncle in the
another country after 20 years he's got
married he's had children he's made a
lot of money and now it's time to come
home tomorrow morning for the first time
in 20 years he's gonna see his brother
Esau last time he saw Esau his brothers
parting words were the next time I see
you I'm gonna kill you for what you did
to me and this is the next time and
Jacob is scared and Jacob says to
himself how do I get out of this most of
the time when I faced a crisis I lie or
I run away and I hate myself for being a
person who lies and runs away who
doesn't have the gumption to stand up to
the problem I wish I was strong enough
to do it right and it's at that point
that the angel attacks him
who was this angel I interpret it as
Jacob wrestling with his conscience
wrestling with a sense of what kind of
person is it going to be and for the
first time in his life this is going to
sound paradoxical but I think I can make
a case for it for the first time in his
life Jacob is strong enough to let his
conscience win up until that night every
time he has wrestled with his conscience
he's defeated his conscience
his conscience said don't do what it's
wrong and Jacob has said I know it's
wrong but I need to do it for the first
time he lets his conscience win you know
if there is such a thing as how to win
by losing any of you who have teenage
children at home best advice I can give
you is you want to get along with your
adolescence you don't have to win every
argument let them win occasionally
otherwise you come across as a bully
same thing happens when husbands and
wives get in an argument very useful
technique to make a note of this try it
it never fails when husbands and wives
quarrel the first one to say you're
right wins the argument this is how to
win by losing and that's what Jacob does
for the first time he lets his
conscience win and the Bible describes
him at the end of the wrestling match
he's defeated he's weary he's injured he
is limping but the Bible calls him
solemn halt for the first time in his
life why because he has integrated the
two quarreling halves of his soul the
part the part of his soul that wants to
feel important and successful and the
part of the soul that insists on being a
good person he has integrated them and
he has achieved
Shalom he has achieved integrity for the
first time he is at peace with himself
how do you and I manage to do that
how can we achieve a sense of knowing
that we matter to the world a sense of
being important without compromising our
ethical values I promise before I finish
I'm going to give you some suggestions
but first I want to go off on it what I
think is a very important tangent I
suggested at the beginning of the talk
and you all nodded very politely that
everybody has a fundamental need to
think of oneself as a good person if
that's true why does anybody do anything
wrong why do good people do bad things
well sometimes good people do bad things
because they're angry because the anger
sweeps them away so strongly they are
carried away by it that they do things
that in a more lucid moment they would
never have done and afterwards they're a
little bit embarrassed by it sometimes
good people do bad things because
they're scared they feel that their life
or their safety is at stake and they
have to protect themselves we have that
story a couple of weeks ago in the Bible
Abraham and Sarah
move from Canaan to Egypt because
there's a famine in Canaan as they're
about to cross the border Abraham says
to Sarah his wife you know you're a
beautiful woman we're heading into a
rough neighborhood I'm concerned that
the Egyptians will kill me so they can
have you let's let's not tell them
you're my wife let's tell them you're my
unmarried sister that way you may be
raped and violated but I'll be safe this
is Abraham the the first person to
introduce us to the notion of a god he
demands righteousness the progenitor of
the three great monotheistic faiths
Abraham doing something so absolutely
despicable and and indefensible how
could he do it
because he's scared for his life and
when you feel your life is at stake
nothing else gets in the way in the
course of my years as a congregational
rabbi I've had members of my
congregations who were survivors of the
Holocaust they would never talk about
what happened to them in the camps not
to their families and certainly not to
me but every now and then I might catch
them at a vulnerable moment I would
visit one of them on the hospital after
they had a heart attack I would see them
at home at a time when they felt their
days might be numbered and they would
break down and cry and they would tell
me things they had done in order to
survive the death camps and how ashamed
they were of having done them and I
would try and hold our hands and dry
their tears and assure them nobody was
going to judge them for what they had
done in those circumstances two other
reasons why good people do bad things
and I think they're very instructive in
Jewish theology there is a concept known
as the yetzer Hara it's usually
translated the evil impulse I don't like
that translation because I'm taught that
God has put it in every one of us and I
will not accept the notion that God
created something that's evil God
created a lot of things which can be
misused but nothing that is irredeemably
evil I would translate yetzer Hara as
the egotistical principle the capacity
for selfishness and the important thing
is everybody has one and you cannot be a
complete person without it if you try to
amputate it the way the hero does in the
Stevenson's book dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde
you don't end up with a saint you end up
with an incomplete person it's like
asking a brain surgeon to cut off those
parts of your brain which give rise to
evil thoughts what are you gonna be left
with there is a delicious fable in the
Midrash about the town that one day
captured the yetzer Hara locked it up
and they said wonderful from now on our
world will be paradise nobody will lie
nobody will steal nobody will do
anything wrong well the next day nobody
opened his store for business nobody
bought nobody sold nobody went courting
nobody got married and though the babies
were conceived that day why because
these are all things upon which our
society depends and they have an element
of selfishness in them the store owner
the CEO of the company the author of the
book they want their product to be as
good as possible as successful as
possible
men wants to win the heart of the most
desirable woman the woman wants to win
the affection of the most reliable
husband these are things on which our
society depends but there's a little bit
of selfishness in it viii sir Hara if
there any Trekkies in the audience any
Star Trek fans you will remember that
infamous episode where Captain Kirk is
split into two curves one purely good
and virtuous the other completely
malicious and evil and the point of the
story was the good Kirk is totally
ineffective he can't get anything done
he has to be reunited with his evil side
with his aides or Hara to be a complete
personality I will tell you if I have
been given the opportunity I would not
have voted for mother Theresa to
represent me in Congress because I think
you can be a saint or you can be an
effective politician but
can't be both and by the way that's not
a knock on politicians if anything is a
knock on saints that I really would not
trust them to function in the real world
to make the kinds of arrangements to
insist on things to make trades and
compromises that ineffective public
official has to do we all have the
yetzer Hara and in fact the Talmud tells
us that the greater a person is the
greater is this yetzer hara let me show
you how this plays out would you all
agree with me that Martin Luther King
jr. was one of the greatest Americans of
the 20th century what he did to cleanse
this nation's soul of the stain of
racial segregation is incalculable he is
one of our heroes well in recent years
we have learned that while he was
leading the civil rights revolution dr.
King was also spending time in hotel
rooms with women he was not married -
what do you do with that information
I don't want to have to say that the
civil rights revolution was morally
flawed because its leader was a serial
adulterer but I also don't want to say
that hey adultery can't be that bad if
Luther King did it and Bill Clinton did
it and John F Kennedy did it and
Franklin Roosevelt did and those are
only the ones we know about what I end
up saying is good people do good things
because they're good people and good
people do bad things because they're
human and they have a yetzer Hara and
they have the streak of selfishness in
them I mean nobody would run for
president if he didn't have a tremendous
ego to believe that you could really
have this job story that's been going
around recently I don't know if you've
heard it is that George W Bush calls Al
Gore and says we found those 600 votes
for you in Florida you want this job you
can have it
nobody would set out to change the
pattern of racial integration in this
country unless they had a tremendous ego
to believe that he could really do
something like that and sometimes that
kind of immense ego which caused us so
much good tap and overflows its
boundaries and ends up with something
wrong but you can't amputate the eighths
of our raw all you can do is domesticate
it tame it teach it to serve your
purposes instead of the other way around
you know when a guy wants to get strong
and build muscles he goes to the gym and
he lifts weights a process that my
daughter the personal trainer calls
resistance training well if you want to
become morally strong you do the same
thing you make yourself strong by
pushing off against temptation by
wrestling with your demons and with your
angels by taking on the Yeats or Hara
and taming it domesticating it another
reason why good people will do bad
things every now and then in the same
way that a healthy cell in your body
suddenly turns it becomes cancerous and
malignant sometimes that healthy normal
craving for significance for a sense of
importance metastasizes into a craving
for power over another person are you
familiar with the Stanley Milgram
experiments maybe you know it that you
know him to recognize his name Stanley
Milgram was the psychologist at Yale who
hired several dozen assistants to help
him with what was supposed to be an
experiment in negative reinforcement he
said to them you see the man on the
chair over there with all the wires
hooked up to him he studied this
material I'm gonna ask him questions
about it every time he gives me a wrong
answer you press this button and you
will give him an electric shock if he
keeps on giving me the wrong answer I'm
gonna turn up the dial you hit the
button he'll give him a stronger
electric shock and then dr. Milgram said
if you're not comfortable with this you
don't have to do it just get up and walk
out now or at any point in the
experiment if you're not comfortable
with what I'm asking
do stop and there be no negative
consequences truth be told the man in
the chair was an actor and the real
subjects of the experiment were the
assistants Milgram wanted to find out
what an average man or woman off the
street
be prepared to inflict pain on a total
stranger whom they had no reason to hurt
if somebody in authority told them to do
it
he hoped they would say no seven or
eight out of every ten said yes and the
actor the man in the chair would scream
and say could we stop now I don't want
to do this anymore this is hurting I I
can't stand this I'm not going to
survive and no camera turn up the dial
and say this is the point of the whole
experiment you've got to be with me now
hit the button
and almost everyone would hit the button
and no firm said now I understand why
good Germans became Nazis now I
understand why a person who was a loving
husband and father regular churchgoer
honest tax payer would do the terrible
things that people did in the in the
Holocaust because somebody in authority
told them to and they had been raised to
obey Authority and their attitude was it
doesn't seem right to me but he must
know what he's doing and so how you know
I'll have to take go along with him if
it's wrong he's the one who's
responsible for years after I read about
those experiments I believe that dr.
Milgram was right last May I decided he
was wrong
last May my wife and I travelled to
Eastern Europe to Lithuania and Belarus
to visit the towns where our parents had
been born and grew up and while we were
there we were taken to the sights of
Holocaust to the killing fields - upon
our outside of Vilna - the ninth fort at
Kovner to the riverbank field where the
all the jews of maryam whole were
rounded up and machine-gunned
we saw the fields the burial places the
pits we read eyewitness accounts
from participants from witnesses from
survivors we saw the pictures of the
Nazis tub and it occurred to me that
Milgram was wrong what those Lithuanian
and Polish and Ukrainian collaborators
did was more than obedience their
attitude was not doesn't seem right to
me but he told me to do it so I'll try
it there there was a Glee there was an
abandonment there was an enthusiasm to
what those collaborators were doing they
didn't simply obey orders they invented
new ways of humiliating the Jews they
were killing before they killed them
stripping them naked and taking children
away from parents and making them dig
their own graves and I understood that
something else was going on this was not
obedience what it was was if all your
life you have been an anonymous clerk an
insignificant shoemaker a marginal
farmer and suddenly somebody gives you
power of life and death over other
people power over other people is a
dangerously addictive drug and they got
drunk on it and they got carried away
with the thrill of having this power
over others which they had never tasted
before there is a theory held by many
criminologist a theory I'm inclined to
agree with but a lot of crime is really
about power that the rapist is not
really looking for sex and the mugger
doesn't really want your money they want
the experience of dominating another
human being
because they're people who don't feel
that sense of importance anywhere else
in their lives who is the schoolyard
bully the kid who is kicked around and
beaten at home and feels so the bottom
of the totem pole that he looks for
somebody else to to kick and to beat up
and if that's a response to a feeling of
powerlessness I think we understand how
revenge works revenge is a very
dangerous very seductive feeling because
it comes to us gar
but in the clothing of justice saying to
us do it to that person because he
deserves it
and that's really not the case my
definition of revenge is justice means
hurting somebody who deserves to be hurt
revenge means hurting somebody because
it makes you feel better to do it do you
remember in the immediate aftermath of
the September 11 attacks hearing people
call into the radio reading letters to
the editor that said let's drop a
nuclear bomb on Afghanistan now I'm
sorry that's not foreign policy that's
revenge that is done solely for the
purpose of saying I don't like feeling
helpless I want to feel powerful again
and all those stories you read about
people throwing stones at the windows of
the mosque beating up the Arab American
gas station owner down the street no
reason for that except for all these
people who felt wounded and powerless
desperately trying to reclaim power
that's what revenge is about revenge
doesn't care who the victim is it just
wants to make you feel potent again and
when you start thinking about that way
there are two things that happen and
they're both bad somebody disses you
somebody treats you wrong and either you
fantasize about getting even with them
but you never do it and then you feel
doubly powerless or else you fantasize
about getting even with them and you act
on it and feel small when you've done it
you know the adage never mud wrestle
with a pig because you'll both get
filthy and the pig will enjoy it
when you have lowered yourself to the
level the person who has done you ill
you feel that you've lost something
Hamlet dies at the end of the play
because his soul has been consumed with
his obsession with getting even Captain
Ahab dies at the end of Moby Dick
because he has used up his soul in the
quest for revenge we are so desperate to
try and reclaim power we don't notice
the harm we are doing ourselves in the
process
so are there honorable ways of
reclaiming that sense of power without
lowering yourself to the level of the
person who has injured you one way if
what was done was really a serious crime
it was really something illegal let the
authorities handle it in my book I
approve it we quote someone who said
everyone except the victim should punish
no one except the victim should forgive
that is we want to take punishment away
from the victim so that it's not done
for a sense of personal satisfaction
it's done to restore a sense of justice
if it's a real crime let the authorities
handle it if it doesn't rise to the
level of a crime you know the person who
dents your car in the parking lot they
the neighbor who's mean to your kids the
neighborhood dog barks all night you
can't sleep what do you do then well
there are ways of reclaiming power I
tell the story in my book in in the
1930s there was a Soviet poet of
prominent Soviet poet the name of OSAP
Mandelstam
he was arrested by Stalin's secret
police and shortly afterwards died in
prison a year later his widow found out
who had turned him over to the
authorities turns out it was a woman
they knew socially a member of their
group who was a professional Informer
she had made herself wealthy and got all
sorts of privileges by turning over
personal friends of hers to the secret
police
mrs. Mangal stop also found out that
shortly this woman would be celebrating
her 50th birthday with a lavish party at
her home and she had a plan
she rounded up all the relatives of the
people who this woman had ruined and
they were gonna crash the party
humiliate her in front of her best
friends expose her for the dishonest
person she was the night of the party
they show up at her house they ring the
doorbell
the woman opens the door sees who's
there and faints at this point something
interesting happens all these people who
had come to expose her to corrupt carry
her in sit her on a sofa get her a glass
of water revive her and leave without
saying a word do you understand what's
going on do you see the process once
they knew they had this power over her
once they knew that she was afraid of
them they didn't need to do anything to
her they didn't need to sink to her
level
just knowing they could restored their
sense of control you know where you've
seen a very similar process happen in
South Africa with the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission in South
Africa when the African National
Congress took over from the apartheid
forces and they understood you could not
put every policeman and every soldier on
trial it would divide the country that
needed to be United it would tie up the
courts for 20 years they set up the
Truth and Reconciliation Commission
policemen and soldiers under a promise
of amnesty confessed to what they had
done wept and expressed remorse more
importantly victims black Africans who
had never been taken seriously had never
been treated with dignity in their lives
all of a sudden were invited to tell
their stories and Supreme Court justices
listened to them
Hendon members of the president's
cabinet listened to them and the
Episcopal bishop of South Africa said to
them you are right and terrible things
were done to you and that sense of
validation that sense of being taken
seriously did more for them than
punishing the policemen would ever have
done once they had that recognition that
validation they didn't need to hurt
somebody else and then if all else fails
there's always one option you can turn
- and that is simply to walk away out of
strength not out of weakness to turn
your back on the incident not saying boy
what I love to get even with you for
what you did to me but I can't figure
out how to do it but saying what you did
was really despicable and wrong and you
don't deserve to mess up my head I'm not
gonna rent you space in my head anymore
because I don't like what you do to me
when I do I'm just not gonna be obsessed
with you because you don't deserve it
you deserve to be punished but I deserve
to be better I deserve better than to be
obsessed with what you did to me forget
about it okay now a few minutes for what
I promised I would do to you and that's
tell you how you can achieve the sense
of making a difference to the world
without compromising your ethical
standards give you a couple of ways just
about three weeks ago I was watching the
opening game of the World Series and if
you remember some of you will remember
it they invited Ray Charles to sing the
anthem and he sang America the Beautiful
and in tribute to the firefighters and
the policemen and rescue workers who had
died at the World Trade Center he sang
the third verse of it the one you never
hear Oh beautiful for Heroes born in
liberating strife who more than self
their country loved and mercy more than
life and when I heard him sing those
lines and thought about the firefighters
and the rescue workers and the policemen
who died on September 11 and when he
sang who more than self their country
loved and mercy more than life I lost it
and I just sat there watching the
television and crying as I watched and
listened now it's not all that unusual
for me to cry at baseball games being a
Red Sox fan at all day
but I was just so touched by that that's
one of the ways one of the ways you
matter what I realized about them at the
firefighters was they gave us the answer
to a very important question if they had
not done what they did we would be
embarrassed by the question our enemies
believed strongly enough in their cause
to give their lives for it do we believe
equally strongly in ours if we did not
have the example of the police and the
firefighters and the rescue workers I
don't know what answer we could have
given to that one of the ways you make
your life matter is by caring enough
about some things that you're willing to
put your life on the line for them and
the best way to do that is to join with
other people I remember when I was a
child I went to a museum once that had a
display about the force of gravity and
they did it by having scales these
scales where you would weigh yourself to
show you what you would weigh on various
planets on the moon which is small and
has a very little a very light
gravitational pull you would weigh a lot
less on Jupiter you would weigh a whole
lot more because it's so big and the
insight I came from that is you become a
person of greater substance if you
attach yourself to a greater cause the
greater the cause you believe in the
more important you become and you don't
have to do it alone you do it by joining
with other people what one person cannot
achieve lots of ordinary people coming
together can make happen the shtetl the
Jewish world of Eastern Europe was a
prime example of the whole being greater
than the sum of its parts ordinary
individuals not very well-educated not
terribly affluent banding together
created a world where everybody was
pious and everybody was charitable and
everybody was hospitable why not because
they believed in it but because their
neighbors expected
of them and who were these neighbors who
expected it of them it was themselves it
was people just like them but because
they all got together and said this is
how we will live they exercised this
tremendous communal pressure and they
changed the world around them another
way in which you can feel important to
the world is what I call being the best
actor in a supporting role we would all
like to be the stars of the movie but
very few of us will end up being the
stars of the movie we can all be the
best actor in a supporting role you have
a friend who's being treated for cancer
her story is a life-and-death struggle
your story is to be the best actor the
one who drives her to in front her chemo
appointments the one who runs carpool
for her when she's not feeling well
who stockpiles some deals to make life
easier for her it's not the drama of
life and death it's the little things
behind the scenes and they make a
difference tremendous difference a
schoolteacher whispers a few words of
encouragement to a student and 48 hours
later forgets she ever said it but that
student feels differently about himself
for the rest of his life
a teenager stops to help an elderly
person who's got a flat tire and changes
the tire for him and drives off and
never gives it a second thought but how
many people will that elderly man or
woman tell about the incident and how
many people will have a different
opinion of today's teenagers because of
them and the teenager who's stopped will
never realize the effect yet the ripples
that are sent out by every little deed
of kindness and thoughtfulness we do
there is a story in the Bible in the
book of Genesis Jacob sends his favorite
his beloved son Joseph out to check on
his brothers he says to them Hugh
brothers are out taking care of the
sheep go see that they're okay Joseph
goes to where he expects to find them
and they're not there and he looks
around and they're nowhere to be found
and then there's this man in the field
who says what are you looking for kid
and Joseph says I'm looking for my
brothers and the man says oh those must
be the Shepherds I heard them say let's
go to Delta
so Joseph tracks them down in Delta
sure enough they're there when they see
him all the jealousy all the resentment
builds up in them they grab him they
sell him to a caravan into slavery in
Egypt he goes down there saves the
Egyptians from famine the Israelites
migrate down there and the story goes on
from that what's the man in the field
doing there where does he come from why
is he there
the Bible has minor characters but the
Bible has no superfluous characters if
that man in the field is there he's
there for a reason the reason is if
Joseph doesn't find him doesn't find his
brothers he goes home and says pop I
don't know what happened they weren't
where they were supposed to be he's
never sold into slavery
there is no Israelite migration to Egypt
no enslavement under Pharaoh no Moses no
Ten Commandments the whole world is
different he supposed the men in the
field remembered having a 30-second
conversation with a teenager who
couldn't find his brothers and if he did
remember it these suppose had ever
occurred to him that that 30-second
conversation changed the story of the
world not likely but there you have an
example of Best Actor in a supporting
role
one little deed we have no way of
knowing how far it's ripples extend you
lend a friend a book and the book helps
your friend understand herself and her
family you invite a friend to a party in
there he meets the woman he will marry
little deeds not terribly important in
your own scheme of things but they
affect the lives of so many people
that's what it means to be Best Actor in
a supporting role and we all have the
capacity to do it and finally most
important and most accessible way in
which we can satisfy our craving to know
that we matter that the world is
different because of us if we didn't
understand this before September 11 we
should have learned this lesson that
terrible Tuesday did you notice when the
people on the upper floors of the World
Trade Center realized they might not
make it down to safety and when the
passengers on the airplanes the hijacked
airliners realized
what was happening to them and some of
them had their cell phones with them
did you notice nobody called his broker
and said sell my American Airlines
shares nobody called the office they
called their families their last words
were if I don't make it I just want you
to know I loved you and I love the kids
face to face with the prospect of dying
they realized that was the most
important thing they had to say that's
where our immortality will come from
that's the lesson Tullio to learn and in
the days after September 11th we started
to learn more about who those people
were on the airplanes and in the office
buildings as their obituaries started to
appear some of them were very highly
placed executives in important
corporations some of them were founders
of high-tech firms some of them were
very successful men and women but did
you notice nobody talked about that they
only talked about what loving husbands
and fathers they were what special wives
and mothers what good friends and what
valuable members of their community
that's what people are remembered for at
the very end of the book of Genesis
Jacob is on his deathbed he's an old man
and realizes he doesn't have much longer
to live he's lived a long and full life
in three different countries met all
kinds of interesting people but looking
back over that long and full life there
are only two moments he remembers he
remembers that when he was a teenager
and didn't like the kind of person he
was God appeared to him and said it's
okay he'll help grow it and you'll grow
up to be somebody really fine and he
never forgets that and he remembers once
he knew what it felt like to love
somebody he fell in love with Rachel by
the way Jacob is perhaps the only
character in the entire Bible who falls
in love everybody else takes a wife
Jacob falls in love and is changed by
that
at the fall of loving someone the same
Jacob who would not give his starving
brother a bowl of soup unless he got
something more valuable in return that
same Jacob is prepared to work seven
years for no wages to win rachels him
and he loves Rachel and she loves him
and that changes her it liberates her
from being labels daughter and permits
her to be a person in her own right and
Jacob realizes and Jacob with his
enduring memory teaches us Rachel died
young decades later he is still warmed
by the memory of that love he looks back
and remembers once I loved somebody and
that changed me and that changed her and
that's how we have our impact on the
world we don't have to look to matter
on a global level on a national level we
don't have to worry about getting our
names in the papers or on the front door
of the office you reach out to the
people closest to you you love them you
invite them to love you you change every
life you touch there was an Israeli poet
by the name of you you would the Amish
ie
died about a year and a half ago who
wrote a poem once about what happens to
all the love you've received in your
life when a person dies and he has this
fantastic image he suggests that in the
course of your life a body absorbs all
the love it's exposed to from parents
from brothers and sisters from friends
from lovers from spouses from children
and it absorbs all that love and then
when the body dies on a high rights
like a broken slot machine discouraging
all the coins of the generations it
pours out all that love back into the
world recycling it so that people die
but love doesn't die the love is
permanent and it changes everybody it
touches at the very end of one of my
favorite books of the 20th century
Thornton Wilder's little novel about why
good people die young the bridge of San
Luis Rey while their rights on the last
page
soon we too will die and for a little
while we will be remembered and then
will be forgotten but we will have loved
and the love will be enough there is a
land of the living and a land of the
dead
and the bridge is love you want to know
that you have made a difference you want
to know that there are people out there
whose lives are different because of you
everyone you have loved and everyone
you've invited to love you everyone you
have reached out to and everyone you
have done little deeds of kindness or
you changed their lives
you've mattered the world is a nicer
place a warmer friendlier place because
you were part of it and that it seems to
me is all the immortality
we crave thank you very much
we did promise you some time for
questions to this this is the part of
the evening I always look forward to
this is going to get my material for my
next book one of the questions you asked
ma'am I think you were the first
question please
oh we're coming with a mic how there's
one rabbi thank you so much you are
endlessly inspiring I have read two of
your books I don't have a question I
really want to make a comment because
it's so light of what you just said when
my mother died our rabbi who was the
very good friend of the family spoke as
a eulogy and he said everyone can be a
person but that everyone can be a mensch
and I think that kind of sums up what
you say so thank you very much thank you
it's exactly what I was saying I enjoyed
I enjoyed listening to you very much
especially the ability that you have to
become serious and at the same time also
voice a good sense of humor my question
involved the fact is that you indicated
that Abraham had performed an evil act
with his sister with his wife indicating
that she was his sister it was my
opinion that he had a mission to perform
giving to him by God and that it was an
all important duty for him to continue
that being the first circumcised person
in this universe and that mission was of
all importance that he had to have taken
that risk to continue it especially
since he had no children as of that time
and the children first came later on so
you certainly welcome to your opinion
the wonderful thing about the Torah is
that it could be interpreted in so many
different directions I just read a yep a
brief biographical sketch of a man who
was studying to be a cantor born
non-jewish converted to Judaism and he
tells the story of why he converted he
says he once sat in honor this
of a particular portion of the Torah and
people disagreed with each other sharply
in vociferously and just couldn't accept
each other's point of view and at the
end they all went off and in enjoyed and
hugged each other and felt very close
and he was so moved by the fact that
Jews could differ so sharply and still
feel that they're part of the same
continued woman and you don't match each
other in in their regard for Torah I
love the fact that in our tradition we
can differ and we can interpret all
these stories in different ways so thank
you for your comment sir thank you you
touched tonight on a subject that I have
trouble for many years you spoke about
the Holocaust and you spoke about
revenge and I asked you could you
explain what was the revenge for the
Holocaust and how should we handle that
paying and what did the people that did
those horrible things how was it justice
to them either how I strive to get even
with the Nazis for what they did to our
people by not being obsessed with them
my revenge on the Nazis is to say get
out of my head I am NOT going to permit
you to mess up my thoughts I'm not gonna
permit you to distort my understanding
of Judaism so that I think of being
Jewish in terms of being a victim
instead of in terms of being people who
teach the world about God
Laure by I have wondered for probably 15
years after reading your book why it bad
things happen to good people and my
recollection is that you summed up part
of it by saying that things just
happened
there is no reason and is that my is
that correct understanding yes you
remember it very well but the two
messages of the book are first that if I
must choose between an all-powerful God
who is not fair
or a fair God who is awesomely powerful
but not totally powerful
I would rather affirm God's goodness and
compromise his power and the second and
half of it is that a lot of things
happen like the events of September 11
which have no meaning until we give them
a meaning and we give them a meaning by
how we respond to them so that when
tragedy strikes individuals tragedies or
national tragedies they have no meaning
until we decide will that cause me to
despair and give up on life I have this
confrontation with a man in Cleveland
where I was speaking last week who said
that and very angry terms that he was so
upset over the Holocaust that he's he
finds it very hard to believe in God and
I said to him I understand where you're
coming from but I find it interesting
that you were so angry at God for not
existing
oh yeah my question is do you believe
that there is a faith beyond reason of
course there's a faith beyond reason I
mean my God if we only did things that
made sense would we ever get married
would we ever have children
would we ever choose our professions no
I think there are a lot of things that
one does if anything the fact that we
are so outraged by the crimes by the
death of the young person by the
automobile accidents is in a roundabout
way a kind of a tribute to the fact that
in God's world most things work out all
right no I think there certainly is a
faith beyond reason it needn't
contradictory XANA transcends reason was
this so insane so what do you would you
say that there is a purpose for
everything that happens no what I'm
saying is many of the things that happen
have no meaning until we impose a
meaning on them we can respond to
tragedy by despair and anger or we can
respond to tragedy with compassion and
car and the event has no meaning until
we decide how we're going to react to it
if what you're asking is does God have
this elaborate plan which required five
thousand innocent sacrifices on
September 11
my answer is I hope not but
the Holocaust friends own the history of
humanity is the history of genocide the
the tremendous amount of attention paid
to the Holocaust and rightly so of
course I think will probably prevent is
probably an evolutionary step perhaps
because genocide has been with humankind
since the beginning of humankind
sir I'm so glad you said perhaps because
that makes it possible for me to agree
with you it's been 56 years since the
second world war ended and I don't
notice that we've developed the real
distaste for genocide it's happened in
Africa it's happened in Cambodia it's
happening all too many places when I am
asked is the human race getting better
or getting worse my answer is yes I
think the human race is crueler and more
compassionate simultaneously we're
learning how to kill more people and
we're learning how to save lives and how
to try and put an end to it the concept
that the Holocaust was a necessary
evolutionary step is an intriguing one
my initial responses I'm reluctant to
buy into that because I don't think the
Holocaust had to happen I think that was
a choice some very vicious evil death
and enamored people I I just you know I
don't want to believe that it was
necessary I don't even want to believe
that it had to happen so that we could
learn how terrible it is because I don't
think we've really learned how terrible
it is I think it happened because some
very vicious people got hold of the
machinery of an advanced state and used
that machinery to cause incredible
damage not only to Jews but to millions
of people everywhere and frankly I would
have wished it it did not happen it is
for me the enduring proof that once God
gave us the free will to choose between
good and evil
God is not about to reach down and
slapper
away from the cookie jar if we're in the
process of choosing evil and I think the
events of September 11 or another
instance of that yes we'll have time for
one more question please well like to
thank you or I buy for your words of
wisdom
now you've referred to the events of
September 11th several times what you
have not done is indicate what your
reaction or what reaction you proposed
we would take I'd be interested in your
response the gentleman says I didn't
spell out how we should have responded
sir I don't mean to be facetious about a
very serious question but if I had a
good answer for that I would not be in
Washington I'd be in Washington and not
in Miami tonight frankly I'm pleased
with the way our government has
responded to the events of September 11
I'm pleased that we did not respond
immediately just looking for somebody
anybody someplace to bomb so we wouldn't
feel like a helpless nation again I'm
glad that we measured our response
identified the enemy offered them
non-lethal ways of solving the problem
and when they spurned it reluctantly
went into action and I'm glad that we're
trying to to limit the amount of damage
that's being done personally if the
president were to call me and ask for my
advice I don't know that I could tell
him anyway to do it better war is never
good but war is sometimes necessary and
the collateral damage skirting Wars
sometimes is never good but is sometimes
necessary and I have to say that the
people who wrought the tragic events of
September 11 have called this down on
their own heads and that while we are
what we've been doing for the last few
weeks in Afghanistan I'm convinced is
not simply lust for vengeance but is in
efforts to bring about justice and to
save the lives of all those people who
would have been the victims of terrorism
in this country in Israel and elsewhere
if these evil forces were not stopped I
hope you find that a satisfactory answer
can I help
and I would thank all of you for being
the occasion of my coming back to Miami
again tonight
thank you ladies and gentlemen if you
have a book to be autographed please
remain seated if you do not have a book
or wish to purchase one please go
outside we are going to set up an
autographing area here in the front and
people will line up down the center
aisle
thank you for coming and it's over we'll
see you back here next year the weekend
before Thanksgiving